this year's nominees for Best
Documentary Feature scoured the globe to
bring light to stories that might have
remained hidden by chance or by force
the efforts uncovered hidden Beauty gave
voice to the voiceless and dead to speak
powerful truths here are the nominees
for Best Documentary Feature citizen for
Laura Poitras Mathilde bonne voie
and dirt pollutes key finding vivian
maier John Maloof and Charlie Sisko last
days in Vietnam Rory Kennedy and Kevin
McAllister the salt of the earth
VIN vendors Giuliano Ribeiro Salgado and
David Rozier Virunga Orlando ba nines
and L and Joanna nada Sagara
and the Oscar goes to citizen for
thank you so much to the Academy I'd
like to first thank the documentary
community it's an incredible joy to work
among people and support each other so
deeply risk so much and do such
incredible work we don't stand here
alone the work we do to end what needs
to be seen by the public as possible
through the brave organizations that
support us we'd like to thank Radiesse
participant HBO Britt doc and many many
many organizations who had our back
making this film the disclosures that
Edward Snowden reveals don't only expose
a threat to our privacy but to our
democracy itself when the most important
decisions being made affect affecting
all of us are made in secret we lose our
ability to check the powers that control
thank you to Edward Snowden for his
courage and for the many other
whistleblowers and I share this with
plain Greenwald's and other journalists
who are exposing truth thank you